all right President Obama cited George
Washington's farewell address and
announcing his own goodbye speech the
first president published his remarks in
a Philadelphia newspaper in 1796 his
warnings of a partying friend caution
Americans about the wiles of foreign
influence he stressed the union of the
whole it is a message that is repeated
in the Senate every year the name of
America which belongs to you in your
national capacity must always exalt the
just pride of patriotism more than any
appellation derived from local
discriminations with slight shades of
difference you have the same religion
manners habits and political principles
you have in a common cause fart and
triumph together the independence and
Liberty you possess are the work of
joint councils and joint efforts of
common dangers sufferings and successes
The Daily Beast editor-in-chief John
Avlon explores the history and legacy of
that address in his new book
Washington's farewell the founding
fathers warning to future generations
it's published by Simon & Schuster a
division of CBS John Evelyn thank you
for coming great to be here guys so did
it start that tradition but what
Washington said a sense of warning to
the country absolutely so the watch the
farewell tradition was set by Washington
but there's a deeper tradition which is
the warning parting warnings from a
friend where presidents say look I'm
leaving the stage but here's what you
need to know in Washington's case here
are the forces that have destroyed
Democratic Republic's before us so it's
a warning that the president generally
absolutely capsulate absolutely and
Eisenhower's farewell famously captures
that in the military-industrial complex
but it was published in her newspaper an
open letter to the American people and
based on his lessons from history and
his own life he detailed forces that had
destroyed Democratic Republic's before
hyper-partisanship excessive debt
Foreign Wars foreign influence in our
politics yeah forces we still deal with
today so it's a remarkably prescient
relevant document he guest on would
Obama might say well III would not be
surprised if he does include a warning
given the storm clouds on the horizon
it's so interesting as you point out
it's in a newspaper 6080 eight words you
said in the first line of the book the
most important speech you've never read
because he never delivered it but it
still is relevant today on both sides of
the aisle people are quoting it
absolutely and that's one of the
fascinating things you know this was the
most famous speech in American history
was more reprinted than the Declaration
of Independence for the first hundred
and fifty years of our republic and
different parties at different times and
different political leaders have taken
comfort from it Lyndon Baines Johnson
quoted it on the importance of public
education that we need an enlightened
citizenry in a self-government situation
Ronald Reagan always talked about the
importance of religion and morality to a
self-governing people so it's a document
that can unify the nation provide a
sense of common ground and common
purpose and God knows we need that right
and what was the influence of Alexander
Hamilton Hamilton
you know shout out to lin-manuel yeah
Miranda Hamilton wrote many of the words
what's fascinating is that the first
draft was written by James Madison yeah
the second draft the really deep draft
was written by Alexander Hamilton and so
George Washington got the band back
together with a band of brothers who did
the Federalist Papers but ultimately the
ideas were all Washington the words may
have been Hamilton's in many but not all
cases but the ideas were all
Washington's and it really is an
autobiography of his ideas some critics
like Jefferson Madison actually changed
their mind because of the influence of
Washington they did and and Jefferson
and Madison were at war with Washington
for much of his term at the end of
Washington's second term he was brittle
and thin-skinned frustrated by attacks
in the press and the rise of
partisanship he was and and and Hamilton
and Matt and Hamilton and Jefferson were
at war when pardoned in the warring
papers at the time but when Jefferson
became president he all of a sudden
became a Washingtonian he came up with
the phrase entangling alliances that
many people associate with the speech so
it's also about how when positions of
responsibility are assumed often
people's perspectives change and
Washington's core warning to the nation
the principles he set out remain
relevant today and they tend to be
adopted by people once they've reached
the presidency well you gave a gift to
the reader you include the speech all
6080 words in the book all right John
Alex yeah congrats Congrats and
Washington's farewell goes on sale
Tuesday